the radicals won the campus fights of
the 1960s and they now run those
universities as tenured radicals to
borrow a phrase from Roger Kimble today
according to a number of surveys some
24% of college professors in the social
sciences call themselves radical 21%
call themselves activists 18% call
themselves marxists the ratio of liberal
to conservative professors according to
another survey is 8 to1 in polyi that's
pretty bad it's 17 to1 in history
departments it's 44 to1 in sociology
it's 48 to1 in English and it's 108 to0
in race and gender
studies I don't really know how that one
works I was not a math major but I
suppose I would even think it might be
higher